14,8 millions de personnes fragilisées
par la crise du logement plus de 4
millions de personnes non aux mal-logés
300000 personnes aujourd'hui sans
domicile un nombre qui a doublé en une
décennie et triplé depuis 2001 depuis
décembre 2021 près de 4000 personnes ont
tenté chaque soir en vain de joindre le
115 faute de places d'hébergement
disponibles à la mi novembre rien qu'en
seine-saint-denis 60 enfants de moins de
3 ans et à la rue n'ont pas pu être mis
à l'abris pourtant il y a cinq ans elle
était ambitieuse la promesse faite aux
mal logés la première bataille
ces deux logiques tout le monde
dignement je ne veux plus d'ici la fin
de l'année à voir des femmes et des
hommes
dans les rues c'est une question de
dignité c'est une question d'humanité et
d'efficacité là aussi alors il faut
préciser que le président de la
république parle est ici de la situation
plus spécifique des sans abri demandeurs
d'asile une promesse ciblées qui n'a de
toute façon pas été suivies de mesures
suffisantes plus largement les moyens
déployés pour lutter contre le mal
logement au cours de ce quinquennat
n'ont clairement pas été à la hauteur
des enjeux depuis 1984 l'effort public
pour le logement n'a jamais été aussi
faible les aides au logement sont en
effet passés de 1,82 pour cent du pib en
2010 est à 1 63 % en 2020 la production
annuelle de logements sociaux n'a
quasiment fait que baisser ces dernières
années et l'offre a progressé deux fois
moins vite que la demande et c'est sans
compter les coupes dans les aides
financières à destination des plus
précaires comme la baisse des apl par
exemple la part du budget de l'état
consacré au logement est passé de 42
milliards d'euros en 2010 est à 38
milliards en 2020 15 milliards d'euros
d'économies ont été réalisées sur ce
quinquennat alors que les recettes
fiscales ont augmenté
tout ceci en cohérence avec un axiome
maintenant bien connu
des responsables et on est dans le
curatif on met un poney nain dans des
minima sociaux et impôts
on n'en sort pas alors évidemment cette
période de campagne les voeux pieux
reviennent à la mode et certains
candidats à la fonction suprême ont fait
des propositions comme jean luc
mélenchon avec son plan mal-logement 0
sans abri d'ici cinq ans une promesse
qui rappelle celle d' emmanuel macron en
2017 de nicolas sarkozy en 2006 ou même
de lionel jospin en 2002 quant au
premier rappel de l'abbé pierre en
faveur des sans abri et des mal logés
c'était le 1er février 1954 il y à 58
ans